[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks here we are we might be drunk
we're back good to be here we got a hot
guest
what's up boys how we doing hey i'll
take it stopper was healthy i know
you're gonna [__] it we were all just
sitting here no energy whatsoever you
just you just turned off stepped into it
you gotta bring it up you know it's a
show no this is an exciting guest snappy
baby stavros hulk this is right new
special on youtube crushing it two
million at this point who knows where
it'll be when this comes out two mill in
two weeks feels good that's your record
yeah it might be a record you hit a
million in four days i was tracking it
yeah million in four days yup yup and
then yeah i mean it's going great like i
was wanting i was like let me just put i
mean really you guys are
like you're you guys started doing
youtube specials i mean i remember we
were literally on this block do you
remember because we were doing pod don't
lie on this block you got a call and i
gotta call it hbo pass yeah
and you're like i don't know man maybe
i'll go to youtube and you really didn't
want to and like it's turned out to be
all of you guys doing and me doing is
turned out to be the best thing for our
careers yeah yeah that was doing youtube
special so yeah to the people yeah
anyone even now it's like you just have
that link you're just like totally
here's a little link click and any
[__] in the world can see it you know
exactly there's no blackouts it's just
you know people from [__] denmark are
like this is a good special right right
that's the coolest part is you're like
literally getting messages from people
in like poland who are like
you need to come to poland you're like i
won't but i appreciate them
isn't that the weirdest when are you
coming to bangladesh
that's not going to happen you get
messages like we got norm and i get a
ton of messages from india hell yeah
huge in india really yeah i don't know
why india but that we get a lot of you
know the first when i had a lot of
message from india was the infancy of my
uh
instagram where i was just fully nude
and it was a bunch of it was a bunch of
horny gay indian men from india
and it turns out even the gay the gay
ones behave the same way as the straight
ones when they were like they're like
when come let me see penis
[Laughter]
some guy literally
the first time i i learned my lesson to
never open a photo from an account i
don't follow it was straight up a
[__] indian guy the resolution on the
camera it must have been like an android
from 10 years ago yeah it's blurry it's
like you know he's in a [__] house
with just exposed wires just his dick
fully out beating off in like some shack
and wherever the [__] he's from i was
like you know what i'm gonna [__] i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna skip opening
these from now on
i'm not gonna
put a guy with pictures and he's like
dude you were asking for it yeah he
knows those poses true he did frame his
[__] in a way it still haunts me the
like the cinematography of that jackoff
video because it was like from
underneath so his dick looked way too
big it was like like a like a like a
blimp coming into frame slowly you know
what i mean
i love the guy without running water but
he has wi-fi yeah yeah
i mean i thought it was honestly one of
the funniest things that's ever happened
yeah i'm like this is wild you don't get
some guy is getting i don't get really
dicks oh wow you're big and gay
instagram imagine the game mateo will
send me links he's like it's me and you
neck and neck and hot as gay i'm like
what the [__] well you're that you're in
good company he shredded him
he's so much hotter mark has also posted
a lot of shirtless pics though
that is that's
one a year yeah i don't want to be that
guy yeah yeah but you do yeah one a year
is enough yeah because in like three or
four years there's going to be a few of
them true i mean you you get messages oh
the gays
and you feel like how a woman would feel
you're like oh i get it this is like a
lot right there's a lot of dicks i get
i'll get messages from gay guys
sometimes but it's never i never get a
dick oh i'll send you some of mine
they're respectful with you you put out
a bunch more we're a couple [__]
cox blazing with me and mark but you
they're like i gotta chat him up see
what how his day was
take me to dinner yeah yeah yeah that's
what happened the weird thing is you get
enough dicks and you start like
comparing you're like well this one it's
like baseball cards
[Music]
of course should we get a drink in here
let's get it there you left so now we
have mccoy i guess what's your what's
your bar name going to be
this is our backup bartender
[Laughter]
we got jb we got jv coming in this is a
greek episode here i love flag thank you
i do i by the way hugely appreciate the
layout very much you becoming the most
prominent uh greek i'm ho you know i'm
just stamos here i come [__]
giannis is out yeah
giannis we love you
it doesn't have to be a competition here
cheers
there we go i'll break some i'll i'm
going to smash this right after i drink
it
that's really good oh hell yeah whoa
you know this is really yeah uzo's good
this is a chipset i like what you did
here because uzo usually the only way
i've ever had it is straight up like
uh
like with water like that's usually
because it's pretty it's a little sweet
to begin with but i've never had a
cocktail with it and this [__] [__]
rocks what is it right
it's like a cooler liqueur yeah but it's
like it's like like women cello or
something
no it's like it's b it's like some kind
of like not mint exactly like some kind
of like
gummy i don't know what's the let's see
here like a gelatin
a nice flavored yes yes yes i don't know
what it gets cloudy you when you put a
little water and it gets cloudy it's
pretty [__] it's sweet on its own so
this is [__] sick this is amazing
what's the liquor in here oozo that's
the look oh it is a liquor okay
yeah oh man this is damn good yeah this
is [__] dull you've been to greece a
bunch oh yeah yeah and i dude i wanted
to go this because like so i fit so
literally
even though this is like this will be
recorded this will be released in the
future i just wrapped up a [__] you
know nine month tour and wow
it's been [__] wild and it's like my
first time just
completely road dogging it i mean this
after the [__] pandemic i was like i
have to make up a year's worth of money
you know what i mean and i was like i
was like and just i want to grow as a
comic and i was planning on shooting
something so i was just like
once we were open i was like [__] it i'm
like i'm not taking any time off i'm
gonna go balls to the wall so
i uh you're the only two people that i'm
about to because like when i say that
people are like wow that's crazy you
guys oh yeah you were just doing comedy
that's what it is to you two [__]
you are desperately trying to fill those
different holes in your in your souls
with stand up
and it's never gonna be full it's really
it doesn't
this is not the solution
i don't know how many times i've had to
tell sam specifically
you're right the combo of comedy boos
maybe after this glass hold on
but anyway i really wanted to go to
greece but dude it's just all that
[__] travel like i was i was coming
back from
an la flight and i was like i have to do
something twice as long as this to go
relax for a week exactly so i think this
year i'm just going to [__] keep it
local i might go to some [__] i might
go to [__] ocean city maryland baby
acnd you know i'm doing like hudson
valley i'm doing like i do rhinebeck
maybe that's what i'll go with maybe
we'll go what's up
[Laughter]
[Music]
he said he's i don't want to blow his
[__] up he said he might have a party
soon that's what i heard we might be
over there boys
although
when is it a weekend like of course it's
gonna be a [__] weekend knowing tim
yeah yeah yeah he's gonna make you
cancel something yeah
i like the road though did you did you
uh tape it you taped it at the beginning
of the tour though right i taped it in
the middle so i didn't going into the
tour i wasn't exactly sure because it's
also you know you're rusty you don't
know what the [__] gonna happen so i
was like [__] it might take me a year to
remember how to do stand up so i booked
this [__] like almost year-long tour
and i also just wanted to hit every
major
market that i hadn't been in
and then it was like i was like oh [__]
like within two months i was like oh
wait no i can do stand-up again like
honestly it was it took like a month to
really feel like you were there right
and then it took another month to kind
of get the material into shape and i was
like [__] this is like
this is too long like i was gonna
initially record at the end of the tour
i was like [__] that so i was like
literally i just i was like can we just
do it like now can we do it in like
december and so i record in december you
know in l.a and um because i like the
laundry room
a couple reasons i really like the lodge
room and there's like that old masonic
yes like temple it was used to be a
masonic temple and it was like so it
[__] felt cool felt no one had shot a
special there i mean comedy central
swagger jacked me after i shot mine they
released one of those like uh one of
those like
they just stole you know they just like
they they i'm joking but they they
started shooting they shot something
where it was like
those like five minute sets they shot it
there
i was like oh come on you [__]
the whole point was no one else had shot
anything yeah and in between i know
nobody sees that [__] yeah yeah
we're saying
i did that with like the dan i was like
i was like no one's doing the den and i
merely got to call like two other people
are beating you to it
but anyway so i did it for that and also
like for [__] cost measures right
like you guys shot your own [__]
specials this [__] [__] it's up to so
i wanted to get i wanted to look
great and if you're in la and you do and
it was a [__] monday
so it's like la a monday you can get a
crew that's just like not doing [__] and
it's like hey will you work for a
quarter what you're worth because it's a
[__] monday a half half day of work
and it'll be really cool and it's like
so we convinced the great crew to do it
and yeah that was the thing because it's
like you can't [__] come through with
the same [__] yeah i mean like it had to
look a little better than the ones that
were already out because the novelty was
kind of gone so you wanted and that was
always my thing i was like this is on
youtube but it's as good as anything on
hbo it's as good as anything on netflix
so we're gonna make it look like that so
yeah it had to be la or i was flying out
a [__]
top-tier crew to do the kind of show i
got would have probably cost me like 80
grand yeah for some random
you know city so it looked great it's a
killer special and uh that [__]
thumbnail you can't not click on it you
see that mug on that thumbnail you gotta
click the outfit it's perfect perfect
leopard print someone pointed out uh oh
time to suck mark off
he was very clear about what the beep
means
[Laughter]
um somebody pointed out after the fact i
did not realize this at all they were
like he's dressed exactly like ali wong
without even realizing it i completely
stole i'm talking about people stealing
from me i completely stole her whole
vibe and the pregnancy and then the
stomach yeah
adult cobra yeah
yeah the first one the first one was
exactly the same
[Laughter]
[Music]
side by side we got to send that to ally
damn that's what the internet is
undefeated with you like oh my god i
always kept so people pointed that out
to you so yeah somebody you know some
comment or something which i have i have
cool i broke my i won't read the
comments thing for the beginning because
i was like let's just make sure
you know you're just and now i'm back to
not doing it but you know because and
also the ones in the beginning are so
positive they're there for the first
night exactly no no one's like meh yeah
night one yeah wait till you read mine
but no yeah the comments are great the
special is great
it's always
tough too because i talked to the
youtube guy when i put one out and you
have to watch a certain amount to get a
view yeah and so that means people are
watching yeah the majority of it
yeah no it's crazy like because i've
been i've been doing a lot of [__] on
youtube recently i mean that's helped me
pop a little bit we're just putting the
short videos there so i've gotten to
learn about that [__] and it's like yeah
you look at it and it's like people the
average is 20 minutes which is insane
for a youtube video insane like no one
watches a [__] i mean i know it's an
hour but it's like 20 minutes it's
[__] but it's free also and it's
quality that's the thing that's like
right
i'll i'll i will still rent a movie if
yeah if it's like a good looking movie
totally but uh
a good free special all you need is a
friend to be like you got to watch why
not exactly why not might as well and i
think once like you have this thing or i
don't know if i'm supposed to say but
like
once you put this out and people see the
progress and the success you'll never
have to do another one yeah you know
they're gonna come calling yeah yeah
that's how they were like my agent and
my manager just you know we had the same
agent she got fired i had a manager he
left the business but because of my
special yeah they left
they were like people like it but we
don't understand it and we're gonna
leave but because i had the special with
a bunch of views on it i had new people
scoop me up so it was like the best
thing that ever happened to me yeah some
guy tried to [__] some guy never met
tried to just she just showed up in a
green room and it was like hey and it's
like i have an agent
it's old school yeah yeah yeah how did i
do that to me and we shook hands and as
we shook hands there was a pinky ring
and i was like
can't be a manager with a pinky ring or
a ponytail pick one hold on sam all
right i don't come on here and start
saying anti-semitic things
you're attacking my entire ethos right
now pinky rings and ponytails
i love the idea of the guy coming to the
green room because you know he was all
day he was like here we go baby cologne
putting on my best shirt i'm going to
scoop this guy up i got him yeah yeah
and then you're like can you get out i'm
like i'm just just i'm here with my
friends yeah you know this is a bad hang
you know what i mean it's like i also
just just showing up in a green room is
brutal because it's just like it's a lot
i just need it's it was a small green
room
yeah there's not enough space and now we
gotta make small talk just for [__]
the hang up yeah be annoyed let alone
exactly anything else i did that when i
was a young com i did that to a big
comic i was friends with his opener and
he's like oh you want to come hang out
in the green room and i was like do i
and i went in and i was couldn't believe
how cold the headliner was to me and now
i totally get it yeah yeah yeah yeah
now you're actually friends with rob
schneider
what do you think push dudes piccolo 3.
but no now i get it but at the time i
was like wow this guy's mean yeah so
like i can see it from both sides i'm
just tired they're tired and they're
like
really it dude why do i have to
entertain you yes you came in here i
could entertain you yeah i'm at work
yeah please yeah i fully
totally and that was the thing i was
just tired of doing stand-up by the end
of this tour where i was just like i
love it it's fun
you know i like it was is important for
me to get the skeleton of a new hour
down yeah and i have like 45 it's not
obviously i'm not recording it tomorrow
it's not ready but it's like you know i
think when it all is said and done it's
probably a really really good half hour
in there somewhere
already you know you gotta you gotta
[__]
figure it out from there but yeah that
was the thing where i was like if
anybody by the end dude i can also see
how people become entourage guys i'm
totally in there where it's like i
brought a friend to sell merch just a
hand eldest yeah eldest my boy shout out
to eldest um yeah he's out there we i
brought sally cues with me to do on uh
it was just everyone they kind of take
the shape of entourage he's drama
[Laughter]
so i get it dude i fully i fully get my
my dream is to travel everywhere with
four men in track suits
so you say what like why do you do the
road first off i love it second half i
bring gary veeder with me yes james webb
has been coming with james rules i just
i have like a cool crew yeah i love it
yeah it's tough and you can't gamble out
there with these local like local
openers it's really true it's tough i
had a funny guy in tampa though kristoff
jean he was uh jean he was really funny
every now and then you get a diamond in
the room totally it's rare but then even
it's just like it's kind of like we were
talking i think a little bit before the
show
i feel like so much of our lives are
podcasting that it's hard to remember
what was said on mike and what wasn't
but sure but it's like you also just
want to get the right type of opener too
yeah like sometimes a club like if it's
funny when people don't really
understand how to book things and it's
like oh i know who you'll like so you're
going to love your opener he's he's
exactly like you right he's some fat guy
that talks about his little dick
just you know less accomplished with
less good jokes you know what i mean and
it's just like it's like he's a cool guy
i like him and i see what he's he might
even be me ten years ago yeah i mean yes
but i don't want me 10 years ago opening
for me you know i want like a like a
like a lesbian housewife someone who i
have nothing in common around you know
what i mean like someone who has a
completely different perspective on
things so so it's like when you bring
your friend and it's just like you know
it's just fun to have you guarantee you
know what you're walking into you know
you get you you need a different opener
i i've had that two-hour show up and
it's like a tall dude with one eyebrow
yeah he's doing dead baby jokes i'm like
come on and it's like just just they're
just watching a worse version of you you
know what i mean where it's like that's
not how you want to get like if you were
about to eat a like a perfect like you
know perfectly cooked rare steak you
wouldn't want somebody just throwing you
some [__] steakhouse
i'll have a deviled egg i have a scallop
you know what i mean like you know you
don't want a shitty or so anyway and and
not only is it a shittier version but
they're stepping on all the subjects all
premises so you're like [__] yeah now i
can't do mine because it looks shitty
tacked on after doesn't mean we don't
think they're funny too it's just you
don't want them on your show
and that's why that's the lessons you
learn when you start headlining and you
look back kind of what you said with the
green room i owe so much to bobby kelly
because the fact that he had some little
fat kid doing just [__] fat jokes in his
fat jokes
it's like i don't like i'm going to kiss
him on the lips dude i could say the
thing about david tell 100 no literally
when you said like you just want a
shittier version opening the first thing
i was like i used to open for davidson
we were both just worst versions of the
guys who brought us on so they're better
people than us yeah oh yeah i can say
the same thing about amy schumer
i'd suck dick
dude
yeah that's great what were the what
were the best cities for you um you know
i don't know i liked i liked portland a
lot honestly i like the i love portland
yeah it's great you know why is there
such a bad rep i feel like a lot of
comics [__] on it
i like it too i think if they [__] on it
people can can really be like if you're
just looking at it from like a newspaper
like perspective and they're like oh
it's all the [__]
antifa and
it's proud boys and hipsters and it's
like yeah those exist but it's like it's
a [__] cool city everyone is just
kind of like it is a little wild it is a
little like all the strip clubs all the
like it's a decadent city i didn't i
didn't because it's like the most strip
clubs in the country i had just come
back from greece actually that was that
was the first one of the tour it's so i
don't know if this ever happens to you
guys i feel like this is having me the
last two tours where last tour you know
years ago i started in chicago shows
were unbelievable
i was like this tour is going to be the
best one and then eight duds in a row
and then that's exactly what i mean
portland was [__] unbelievable like
i'm like i had just come back from
vacation it was the pandemic i was
worried the shows couldn't have been
better and i'm like this is going to be
[__] i'm the king of cop you know
yeah [__] bernie mac and then and
then i go to you know seattle shows like
whatever you know what i mean
i go to [__] you know i remember
tampa you know what i mean it's like
good shows some good show some bad shows
it's just like you start with those like
just crushing weekends and you think
you're in for it for good and then you
know you just hit a friday late show at
a [__] and it's like or or what
started happening to me is the saturday
late shows used to be the funnest and
now it's like they're too [__] up they
flip yeah the early show is way better
now yeah yeah yeah so true but markets
when you get more into comedy you're
like man markets are important yeah you
should be like oh i'll go to any city
i'll make them laugh but
i'll sell out here and then i'll go to
alabama i just did huntsville and it's
like yeah it's a little light out there
oh i forgot about light out there like
you don't hear that anymore
they also did not they were not down
with me making fun of the the nazi who
they named the museum after oh
yeah
i thought you have to joke about brawn
yeah they were just like absolutely not
i'm like you gotta at least let me make
jokes about it
they named the synagogue after that
[__]
that guy's name was on everything
it really is it's everyone's [__]
wild dude that is just like that's the
liberal part of alabama and they're like
we named a museum after a former nazi
he said he was sorry
what do you people want
you got israel and you got an apology
can we call it even
yeah that was that was a tough one but
uh yeah i mean i really like i mean i
like pretty much
you know i just like the [__] places
you'd think i'd like you know like like
you know portland is it like anywhere
where there's good food and it's just
like kind of a [__]
like a place for adults
behaving like children you know what i
mean it's like you're going to get you
know weed weed
girls
girls are going to [__] for no you know
like easily portland's so sick for that
reason you know what i mean like yeah
austin even though austin's got a little
bit too scenic exactly exactly but like
you know
i love that atlanta was [__] cool
atlanta's great um but also dude the
reality is i really enjoyed the first
half of the tour and then it just starts
to [__] you got burned down i just
got burned out like i was going you
partied on the road
in the beginning i did yeah as and i not
only party like in portland the reason i
loved it so much because it was almost
like a vacation i was like i'm taking in
the [__] i'm going on little hikes
i'm going to the rose garden i'm going
with like japanese tea guard you know
what i mean like i'm seeing cool [__]
i'm i'm eating it at a time like
renowned thai restaurant i'm doing i
have like a full day's worth of
activities and it's like if you do that
for more than like four weeks you're
just like
[__] tired you can't do it like this
philadelphia i was in my bed
for twelve like i'm just like the show
is at seven
or seven thirty and it's like all right
well i'll get breakfast yeah i wake up
at 1 p.m i get breakfast at a diner i go
back into my bed until 7 until 6 50.
i get there as jp is halfway into a set
i do the first one i lay on the couch i
lay on the couch between eat a chicken a
comedy club chicken tender i'm like oh i
don't want to do this [__] show this
picture of waitress feeding your grapes
yeah
banning you with a big leaf yeah i
completely depleted my health bar right
in the first two months of the tour
where it was just like how much more
this can i [__] do well i wasn't even
trying to get [__] that's when you know
i'm depressed
where's the girls that are my dm's like
do you want to come to a bar i'm like a
bar
even women you want delivery like i
don't want to get takeout
it is a lot of work yeah after a while
yeah dude i do with gary veeder who's a
father and you know he wakes up at like
7 30 8 a.m so i wake up the text like 8
a.m he's already been at the gym he's
like breakfast another a question mark
at like 9 30 breakfast yeah then at like
11am he's like i'm starving i'm like get
something to eat i'll meet you for lunch
you're killing me
he works out every day i mean he's
honest
that's my that's my so the big reason i
want to take a bunch of time off and i'm
taking the whole summer off is like i
gained like probably like i lost much
weight during the pandemic because it
was like comedy was gone i had nothing
to focus on and then i gained it all
back just [__] go having a good time
on the road and i just want to get
healthier but i also just want to get
like habits where it's like all right
man i need to live like that on the road
right i need it's gotta because this is
our lives like this year it was when i
was like i had a big realization where i
was like there well there's no more when
i grow up i'm 33. you know what i mean
i'm a this is it like i'm not like if i
don't start doing some [__] now there's
no one 10 years i can no you know what i
mean you can't live you i could not live
the way i lived this year 10 times in a
row that would be [__] wild we just
had segura on here and he was talking
about bringing he brings a trainer on
the road with him yeah and it's like
he's going in a [__] private jet too
i know but i'm just saying but you see
how like a guy that's successful lives
that way and it's like we it's a wake-up
call for all of us because like look you
know mark and i it's no secret we still
drink a good amount yeah it's like this
is this does take a toll oh my god a
certain point i'm just less of a booze
guy more of a weed guy that's better so
you know that's better i mean it's but
but i still drink it i still get high
but it's like i gotta but that's the
philly literally i took so many yeah
yeah these are great i'm literally gonna
get [__] up uh
[Laughter]
you got to try bodega cat at some point
oh yeah so good um
yeah dude it was like that philly i
literally so the one o'clock was when i
wasn't high i was i slept till i looked
at my [__] phone it was 3 p.m
and it wasn't one of those like wake up
early in and out it was like my first
memory of that day happened at three
o'clock yeah
yeah like school is out they had a full
day of school with these kids and you're
like i better get out of bed
you know with the personal trainer he
does the piano lessons he plays with his
kids he does four podcasts then he gets
in a pj and goes to denver and does an
arena and then he writes a book yeah he
wrote a [__] book and i'm like i get
it you're the man
he makes millions and millions of
dollars a year he's hilarious he's
awesome cool guy
i'd rather have a little edge yeah i'd
rather par i'd rather have some memories
some crazy stories i'd rather have a
hangover every now and then and eat some
chicken fingers
and you know [__] my girl in the
bathroom or the green room yeah
they're doing that oh yeah you [__] in
the green room bathroom sure
you don't have a pre-show ritual
yeah i jerk off in the
middle well either way i have the same
one i [__] his girl
and i jerk off to it
that's uh that's awesome oh yeah it's
fun don't be able to go i used to know
god
yeah first time i headlined it also
though
like he's also in a different part of
his life though too you know what i mean
he's 40 something like that i could see
that like and that's kind of what i'm
realizing is like all right let's start
i listen i'm not done getting [__] up
on the road so but it's like it's kind
of the way like that's how i start i
stopped drinking because i was like
like this much where i was like and now
it's like all right when i'm getting
[__] up i'm getting [__] up yeah
it's like for a reason it's like a you
know i'm getting crabs and i'm drinking
12 beers it's my brother's wedding i'm
getting [__] yes you know so it's got
to be a reason exactly so it's like it's
like we got to look at these weekends
more is just work and then it's like all
right if it's a special thing if you're
an anniversary of something if it's a
great city i have friends coming out or
whatever
then let's let our hair down you can't
eat ice cream every day exactly
boy oh boy am i doing it both
metaphorically
[Laughter]
what's your brand for ice cream i'm a
ben and jerry's guy what's your favorite
flavors um i like to get some kind of
[__] peanut butter
chocolate peanut butter element in the
mix chubby hub and pretzel i love
pretzels pretzels huge they go a little
too heavy on the pretzel in my opinion
but it's close and they have a new one
netflix and chilled i don't know if
you're familiar is that good
that one is kind of exactly what we're
talking about here where it's like a
little it's like basically the same
thing but with a better combination a
better ratio in my opinion interesting
um it's very good ben and jerry i i love
a little cherry garcia man but i've also
been oh yeah that's a classic i've also
been doing that like another fat guy
move where i've i've switched to
non-dairy ice creams to like pretend i'm
doing something healthy where it's like
it's a complete lateral move calorically
but i'm like well it won't hurt my
stomach
i tried it they i didn't think they were
good i tried the non-dairy can be good
almond is not the one you want to go
structurally it falls apart it's too
thin that's terrible
all right all right i'm learning yes
absolutely i'd love to give you we could
this could become an ice cream pod
easy we could do rogan hours what do we
talk about ice cream what are some
no-no's for ice cream other than that do
you [__] with like even the health do
you try like the halo tops i try it you
know it's just it's got to have a good
consistency some of the candy bar one is
okay it's just there's some you know
i'll do
i like to just i like to i like to go
high-end like a van lewin
they're vegans they have a great vegan
one they do have a great vegan
uh you know like it's funny because it's
like in my head when i'm being when i'm
being responsible it's like well i'll
only get an ice cream cone
it's not a whole right it's not a whole
[__] thing so i'm in the [__] ice
cream eyes oh yeah we tried the mac and
cheese on here it was okay sure it's
fine it's too much it's too much you
know what i love the honeycomb is
amazing honey comes they're they're
staple
uh they got a chocolate chip peanut
butter i just [__] up i just [__] up
a nice a nice ice cream cone of van loo
and there was one right by where i was
staying in uh in philly shout out to
healing by the way great club great club
and it was a nice one to end on because
it's like yes you don't have to do too
much work you're right there's only two
shows the saturday shows actually were
the worst ones of the weekend if you can
believe it sunday it's date night so the
regular people come out they buy tickets
thursdays are hot
was incredible and they used to be used
to always be the worst show because no
one knows who the [__] you are yeah
whoever shows up on thursday is a
[__] [__] right but now they
really want to see you exactly so what's
that judy's is it judy's ice cream or
yes is it is that is that the right one
jenny's jenny's jenny's doesn't [__] up
that's a good one you know who else send
us some jennies will you jenny jenny's
just [__] kill her and then also the
milk bar no you're [__] the milk oh
the place is like cereal milk yeah
cereal milk i love shrimp we did a
shamrock shake on this on one of our
episodes i've never felt an alcoholic
yeah hate that
i used to do that and i used to do that
in college and just throw up every time
it was one of those where you would you
would party be like yeah this is awesome
and then i would quiet i would i would
walk outside and i would projectile
vomit in the neighbor's yard and i would
come back as if it never happened like
let's go
dude i love one of my favorite jokes
here's is the the cannonball joke oh
yeah and it was like one of the trailers
for your special it's such a good joke
how you like as a bigger guy you're like
you think i only want to do cannonballs
it's such a [__] great deal
expectations yes yes absolutely the
expectations of a big guy and there's a
lot of tags that i cut out of that where
it was like you know you know i want to
see what the top of the human pyramids
like let me breathe let me breathe at it
what's the air up there like you know
what i mean or i'm tired of chugging all
my liquids you know that's because that
was totally in college it's like big fat
guy come on funny fat guy in college
everyone wants you to chug yeah everyone
wants you to do keg stands you know what
i mean and i totally did it um well
we've seen the movies yeah yeah yeah
what's that guy's name in varsity blues
piggy
bruno no not a pruner
the varsity blues guy i don't know
what is it the big fat guy that was
wearing 69. he died hey bob billy bob
that's it blues was fun i loved it i
don't want your life
john yes
it's just awesome to see john voightner
in a performance like that
ron lester and morbid obesity oh did he
lose it oh
[__] with that guy ethan supply he's
jack too i know he's [__] cool [__]
cool guy yeah rats
that guy's got an either's got an insane
like he's worked with every american
history yeah i mean [__] wolf of wall
street my name is working with everybody
that's what you were thinking my name is
yeah yeah but it's like his career has
been he's worked with pretty much anyone
you'd [__] damn he was so big she is
this correct yeah he [__] rules she's
a cool dude
for wall street's so fun i love that
movie yeah oh it's the [__] it's so
fun it's the [__] best i know a
couple people in it henry zabrowski's in
it barry rothbart's in it there's a
couple comics in there yeah barry roth
was just dancing throughout the whole
movie that's that's what a fun role
wasn't derozan it for a sec too nah show
derose i feel like he was like in the
background or something i don't think so
you're gonna rust with alec baldwin
[Laughter]
how long before he's just like back on
snl yeah
it'll be all matters and they'll spoof
that's
that movie
maybe i was wrong that was crazy i mean
that's the one of the most horrible
things i can't believe
i mean that interview he did was one of
the most cringy like that's what you do
in a spoof of what happened yeah oh
really i didn't watch it
i just watched a clip yeah the clips
were bro he looked weird too he looked
like he'd probably been [__] drinking
i mean he's depressing he killed
somebody you know what i mean like
that's tough to deal with yeah you know
damn yeah on an accident yeah still
great on a 30 rock dude so good unreal
well that's yeah that's the
separate the artist from the art you
know what i mean it's like it's like
some of the best people at like
impressive stuff are bad people sure you
know what i mean it's like and i'm not
even i'm not even that's true just in
general because it's like i i really the
longer i've yeah it's like yeah it's
like it feels like it's zero-sum life
where it's like like a it's like a video
game where you choose what to put all
your points to right empathy for people
that are trying to get famous
the empathy bar is real low you know
what i mean they're not wasting any of
those they're putting that [__] michael
jackson yeah r kelly but also but then
there's like norm who's like my hero
funniest guy ever he can't drive yeah he
can't he can only he uses all his brain
power yeah yeah to write jokes and read
dostoyevsky but he can't [__] drive a
car
that's me minus the deutsches
but i can teach you how to drive he just
was like i'm scared of it i don't like
driving that's crazy i have a license
but i can't really drive i grew up in
new york though you know what i mean
like norm is from [__] rural canada
yeah you think you'd be at least driving
the tractors right right colin quinn was
telling me a story that that leonard
cohn used to go watch norm like every
week in montreal leonard cohen was a
normal fan and norm was like who is this
guy
no one didn't give a [__] and then he
found out who he was he was like i don't
like that i like like country i like
country music he like blew off leonard
cohn
that's so sick
he was the best songwriter i got a
hallelujah for you pal
he's just too genuine to fake it he
can't be like oh nice to meet you man
right right you just can't do that
yeah yeah
no that's [__] do you have any do you
have any peeves either
peeves yeah i actually you know what i
cuz what was the other one there was
running bits wrecks
i got them all but actually this the
separate the artist from the art thing
is a bit that i like i'm toying with
that i can't quite get like because i
want to do something about ancient
greece where it's like well if we're
doing that that's like oh ancient greeks
were pedophiles so it's like i guess i
guess we're not separating the artist
from the art say goodbye to geometry you
know what i mean like say goodbye to
that [__] so i'm working i need a little
something more to it but it's like i
like you know something about like i
don't know if alexander the great was
around today he'd be called alexander
the pedophile yeah yeah yeah he's a
great pedophile yeah
he's good at it
actually he might have just been a gay
guy i don't even know if he [__] kids
i think he did he probably did they they
all did yeah
charlie chaplin's daughter was her wife
was 14. god elvis
yeah
so many pedophiles young people are very
attractive
this here's where mark's like
technically they were a fibophile
what does that mean there's some guy
will make a every once in a while when
the pedophile thing comes up there'll be
a guy on a video like on twitter that's
like pedophiles are young kids a fiba
fire you're thinking that's 12 to six
and it's like okay
you can't be making this distinction
yeah you know what i mean like if you
can't you just can't do that
like ever like i don't like it's always
like i don't know we'll they'll drag
some like uh you know republican
like senator or whatever and then like a
libertarian will come in and be like oh
there's words have meaning
libertarians are like and by the way
there should be no age of consent laws
because that's the state
you know you know dictating what you do
yeah that kind of [__] well that's the
big gillis guy where i'm like oh how'd
we all miss that one about how did they
who came up with the state yeah
like who made the ages because each
state is different
so who was that guy like kentucky 14.
that's such a great premise that's great
no really
that was right there peeves i do have
peeves um
all the all the airline travel right
sure
why on a [__] window plane oh window
seat i already know laying on my brother
[__] can't you put the hat the rat the
armrest up why can't you do it on a
window you know
you know because it's like as if because
you're i'm a man of size mark you're
you're up against this mos you know but
when when you're on like no look the
aisle i get it you put the armrest up
i'm spilling over you know my titties
are blocking the cart whatever
on the [__] on the window why can't i
[__] comfortably lean my entire body
up against the [__] window and not be
wedged why why do i need to [__] uh a
love handle wedge right
what safety thing is going on with the
[__] armrest there interesting you
should make the [__] armrest be able
to go up on the [__] window side
that's a good peeve good that's a huge
cause i'm an aisle guy because i need
the extra space a little bit and you can
[__] let your knee out but
were i i was i was forced to sit window
because of some [__] you know the
planes have been [__] horrible this
whole last three months or whatever i
was forced to go window
i was like what the [__] is this why am
i [__] why am i why are my ribs
[__] getting poked by this [__]
[__] i should be able to [__]
lean fully take a little nap up against
the [__] window anyway that's my
[__] peeve that's it
that's a good piece pisses me the [__]
off i got a flight peeve too please we
do i don't know if it's been everyone
lately but the turbulence has been so
bad lately on every flight i've been on
so i'm on the i haven't experienced that
maybe god is trying to kill you
haven't got me yet [__]
no i'm just kidding
the guy who mocks god and then
immediately he's like but seriously i
don't know yeah suck my dick
so the turbulence is horrible and
there's a couple next to me and the
woman's like ah i'm just like oh come on
now you're freaking me out the husband's
also freaking out i was like oh and
they're like holding each other i'm like
[__] you
that's brutal that was annoying that's
one of those where i'm like if i'm that
guy i'm literally like that's why i
turned like an italian
mob boss that's about to kill you know
it's like they're about to kill you and
they're like don't you want to go out
with some dignity
you want to die like a [__] like and
i'd have to fake it from like that's
your wife dude
you're screaming in front of your
you don't want to give her a little
comfort like
right
he's like
you're wrong
most likely you're going to get out of
it so then you get out of it and you're
just like he's not a man yeah yeah
exactly because i'm like now i'm
panicking in my head because i'm just
like [__] they're freaking out it's
making me a little you know unnerved but
you know they're doing that and then i'm
kind of you're also reminded you're like
oh i'm alone in the world yeah
they're holding each other like no and
i'm just like yeah i mean whatever yeah
if i died i go down yeah
yeah that's a great that's a great and
so the peeve is not turbulence it's
turbulence etiquette turbulence adequate
i love a flight attendant who handles it
with dignity yeah
because we all look to the flight
attendant because they're the ones who
are on every flight and if you see i had
one guy we had really bad terms in the
way there too he was just standing like
this as the plane was shaking i was like
yes yeah that's a good guy respect
because he was kind of like it's nothing
he was just like and you want to see
that as a passenger like that helps it
helps so much we all look to the flight
attendant yeah but you know what they
should do next time a guy's screaming
like a [__] after it all settles down
just go up be like sir here you go and
give him a tampon
mark carries a tampon
my peeve is the [__] announcements we
got too many announcements all right it
never ends and you're like we know all
this it's silly and they they take they
stretch it out it's like don't tamper
play with [__] with touch
reach around on this uh this smoke
detector and then how about this one
when they come down with the brochures
for the for the uh the miles
who is buying them yeah
you know what give me that i'm gonna
yeah you sold me well it's not even
they're not buying isn't it like they're
literally you have to apply for a credit
card yes it's like you expect me to to
fill out paperwork and have you do a
credit check right now yeah on the
[__] plane i know it's crazy it's so
fortunate i hate it i hate the
announcements especially because
i know some people just watch the movies
on their laptops so they don't have to
deal with that but you i'm trying to
watch the winter soldier i'm with i'm
dealing with this [__] yeah
it's a good action scene you disrupted
the flow and then i opened it you know i
really hated
back in the days i don't think they're
in airline america anymore but virgin
back when they were an american airline
you'd get that morning flight you know
it's going to be a long flight and you
just get they do like a black ice black
eyed peas type like rap video
for like the safety they'd be like yes
and you sit down
and it was like it was you know like one
chick two dudes they were like a black
guy and you know they were all just like
and you're hungover
uh during this job being so fun and it
was like a long video dancing so long
we might be drunk is brought to you by
manscaped thanks to manscaped everything
goes down the drain including my career
try their new platinum package it's like
their greatest hits collection the
lawnmower 4.0 has a special blade so you
don't cut yourself and has spotlight to
shave in the dark plus it's waterproof
the weed whacker nose and ear hair
trimmer keeps your hole safe while you
clean up got to keep those holes safe
folks why while their crop preserver and
crop reviver keep you fresh south of the
equator the ultra premium collection
with body wash two in one shampoo and
conditioner and deodorant help you smell
good from head to toe get 20 off and
free shipping with the code drunk at
manscape.com that's 20 off free shipping
with the code drunk at manscape.com
your bowls will thank you and so your
lady or man
yes
hey
we might be drunk is brought to you by
lucy you're a responsible consumer and
you want a responsible way to consume
your nicotine don't you
well if you're looking for nicotine gum
lozenges or pouches to use nicotine to
relax focus or just unwind after a long
day there's only one stop you should
make
lucy
i like this stuff the gum tastes great i
prefer the lozenges because you just
throw them in you're not smacking around
town with the chewing so uh get on it
plus you know
it just tastes good then it gives you a
little jolt that yeah oh yeah it gives
you a kick if i'm hungover
i pop one of those in and i'm like
pretty good it's the least healthy
endorsement of all time also if you're
going to the casino you're hitting the
slots just chew the gum and you get the
same the nicotine without having to kill
your lungs
so you've been looking for an
alternative to smoking why not switch a
nicotine product that can actually make
you feel good and feel good about doing
it tell them how fatty if you enjoy
using nicotine you should definitely
check out lucy's products at lucy.co
that's lucy.co promo code drunk at
checkout also i have to read this
disclaimer warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical remember if you're interested
in a better way to use nicotine visit
lucy.co and be sure to use that promo
code drunk
here here hey folks we might be drunk is
brought to you by factor
if you can't stand the heat get out of
the kitchen factor is here to give you
delicious healthy meals that are ready
in minutes with factors spend less time
in the kitchen more fun in the sun it's
fresh never frozen prepared super good
delicious you won't believe and they're
good for you
with 30 meals offered each week you'll
never be bored with your meal plans each
meal arrives pre-prepared and ready to
eat in two minutes that's faster than
getting a pizza
look at all they got they got vegan
veggie meals low calorie options juices
smoothies
energy bites plant-based bars
extra protein and veggie size to every
meal they sent me a bunch they were
great it's really good it's really good
i went every day i'd give them to the
ladies she's a food snob she liked it
those smoothies are incredible yeah nice
just having the house coconut milk
so good
so i had to go.factor75.com
drunk120
jesus christ
so that's
go.com sorry go dot factor 75.
drunk120 to get 120 off
damn drunk 120.
it's good i really liked it i mean i
think very good in my freezer just for
you never know when you want a quick
two-minute uh heat up you know exactly
yeah so that's code drunk 120 at
go.factor75.com
drunk120 for 120 off healthy eating made
easy get on it
that's going to suck to have that kind
of talent and they're like you booked a
game
you're the virgin rapper
i think that's interesting i am actually
a virgin rapper so perfect
i'm with you on the interruptions oh
[__] they haven't played
that guy cleaned up on this boat oh
totally
oh they [__] adds [__] ads dude
and you're not getting the [__] ad
i'm not even gonna say the thing no they
can suck our dicks yeah it's uh
sheath.com
it's good it really is i know they're a
sponsor but i [__] love that
underwear right underwear i might have
to [__] with it check out she's my
friend oh here it is
this is a high production this is insane
there he is there is toddrick
damn this has got to hurt your street
cred
[Music]
in l.a
what's up with the girl on the right
it's kind of a good song though but they
have talent you know
but when you're hungover on a flight and
you're just like just let me get [__]
a superhero movie so i don't think of
course
exactly
yeah i'd [__] that nun
i've never it's never been a much of a
thing for i guess people like it because
if they're so religious and it's like a
real you know you get you get the
symbolism behind it that's never really
you know appealed to me because i'm not
very religious anyway but what's that
like what's your what's your thing like
a dress up is there one that would do it
for you you know i just like stupid hair
i like dumb wigs i like just i like i
don't i don't know if it's a character i
just i'm a very
simple visual man so if it's like i
don't want necessarily an outfit so much
as i want like dumb lipstick
dumb hair like pink
pink wig or something like that pink wig
is like just interesting makeup just
just you but like a [__] a [__] up
[__] version
it's great like some kind of futuristic
sex bot
like that kind of [__] well that's kind
of a female peacocking you're like yeah
you're going all in you look crazy it's
very feminine too yes give me like bimbo
from the future or you know what i mean
like that's that's kind of my [__] but
yeah i'm with you tats get me i love
tattoos i like nails on a woman sure i
want the whole thing i'm wearing like
nails nails are hot but then i also i'm
like she'll never stick that finger in
my butt
you need a bite girl it's so careful
have you ever seen by girls that have
all their nails and just these two not
done and you're like that's a legend
that's a bi girl absolutely yeah yeah
girl they they keep finger popping nails
yeah yeah right you don't want to set me
up on a date and she goes but you'll
never like her she's bi and i'm like
yeah that's my problem
why wouldn't you like her i don't know i
was like was she gonna be [__] around
with other women constantly she's like
no i'm like i don't get why this is a
deal breaker it sounds great yeah you
know and i wish i mean this this is
another bit that i'm trying to like i
was doing it when i had a girlfriend and
i'm kind of trying to figure out a way
to like run it back but we you know
that's how dumb i understand it is
homophobic but it's like if a girlfriend
[__] a woman i literally i know i
shouldn't feel this way i would be like
nice like that you know what i'm the
same way and it's so stupid and it is
homophobic because what you're saying is
like well that's not a real
that's not a real
that's sexual
fun little thing you know but it's like
it is it's a good point they could be
stolen from you by a woman very probably
easier than violence oh yeah oh she's
fine
they know the clip
spots
and i just do think that like i can't i
can't i'm the same way i can't take
myself from that you know i think it
would probably take losing
your girl to a woman to yeah to be like
you know what i but even then it would
be like
yeah but maybe this time
you know what i mean
yeah you know what you got to do in that
situation if a girl leaves you for a
woman and she tells you you got to go
i'll allow it but i gotta [__] her
i got a [__] and you guys can run off
and she's like i'm
my stuff's already packed mark i don't
know what you're talking about
you know what do you of course not
she weighs more than you
it is i'm good
there was something hot about it yeah
that would be great she's like yeah no
problem and then it's just like just a
girl in a sa in a shirt that i would
wear comes in is the girl in a 2xl
hawaiian it's like
i heard you want a little piece of this
mark
i was trying to work on a bit how it
didn't really work but how like i true
story i saw two lesbians making out and
i was so drunk i just went yes like
loudly and then they stopped making out
and one of the one of them was an
effeminate man so i'm just cheering on
i'm just cheering on there's no coming
back what was he wearing a tank top what
was that he just had like kind of weird
hair
well then you just look like a pro
relationship yeah i'm just like i love
love
good for you guys
heteronormative
[Laughter]
i don't know man yeah but my i mean
this is different for women where i've
had many women behind closed doors say
if my boyfriend ever blew a guy
that'd be the end of that oh interesting
yeah why always really it's weird when
you hear guys like harry styles who are
like it's like sexually fluid i'm always
kind of like is that
at the risk of sounding ignorant is that
i don't know any guys really like that i
don't think what do you mean who will
just kind of androgynous no not
androgynous you mean in their sexual
like heteroflexible guys yes guys that
are mostly straight but ah
everyone saw it might get sucked off
i think we know a lot more and i'll be
honest with you i might be one of those
guys really i've never been sucked off
by a guy but i tell this story a lot and
i don't want to repeat myself but there
was just a guy who reminded me of this
girl i knew
and we were he was like a little blonde
guy
hairless you know what i mean like just
cute mannerisms of a woman and i was
like
ah you know i got i literally had
another show he was like we were
chatting at the bar i was like i have
another spot after this but if i didn't
who knows
well i kind of think i think for me it's
like well i don't even [__] care
anymore like i [__] a bunch of girls
it's kind of lo like just randomly
[__] has kind of lost its mystique a
little bit where i'm like yeah this
would be an interesting night you got to
mix it up it would be it would be
something the post x would definitely be
better yeah yeah
he brings out his xbox
[Laughter]
um but that's pretty if you're gonna go
gay that's the straightest gay
you know like a twinkie
it is the ancient greek tradition of
yeah hold around a little guy to suck
you off after you're you know after
you've been doing philosophy all day
you have your little gay best friend who
sucks your dick but right and that's
separate from your wife who's there from
to make children only you know
that was your gumma back in the day i
was a bro that you could wrestle with
and then
bounce philosophy and theorems off each
other and then he blows you afterwards
sounds like heaven yeah those guys had
it figured out oh yeah but yes i don't
but i do think i don't i don't think i
have any attraction to men is the thing
i just yeah i don't know most men i'm
with you like it it's like it is funny
when you're like like me and my friend
eldest me and my but it's like we think
about that all the time where we make
you know you make the dumb jokes like
why don't you come suck my dick and then
every once in a while you think about
that yeah and it repulses you to your
core it really and you're like how do
women [__] us like that's what me and
elders talk about it's like we are
horror shows you know what i mean it's
like you're some big lumbering hairy
piece of [__] i'm fat as hell but they
like but they like they do like that but
bald some of them like a bald spot yeah
yeah i'm like that's funny what's manly
in a bald spot but i would love to get a
woman's head for like an hour and just
see what the hell is going on because
they're very secretive with everything
what they like they made a movie about
that with mel gibson
they got to get better they got to get
in there more yeah no it's it's uh it is
weird like every once in a while because
i remember older women too are more open
to like whatever is was formerly weird
about us yeah they like i remember in
college a girl wanted me to shave my
chest and then
women now be like i love that you're
hairy totally totally and it's like oh
where were you when i was a kid well i
do when they grow up i think there's an
element of their growing up but also
like
like body body positive [__] has
affected men a lot less like it's
definitely it's body dysmorphia is a lot
worse for women obviously but at the
same time definitely i think there was
like a you know a bit of a [__] metro
sexual thing going on when we were in
our youth right like when you're in your
20s there was a little bit of that
going around where it's like you know
the first iteration of queer eye there
was a lot of like getting your eyebrows
done for the first time was going around
amongst male like it was like a you know
and i think it kind of went swung the
other way and now it's like you know you
can be yourself do whatever you want
essentially yeah and it's like you know
we're so lucky guys are so lucky that
women can see past
the looks so much i mean they can really
like who are you talking to exactly
i didn't want to say it
yeah stage
like you but
you're confident you wear it well yeah i
mean that you're in totally different
i've definitely talked to women who are
like starving so i've definitely talked
to women who are like in the stove for
sure
there's a definite that's the thing
everyone does have a type and it's like
and i do think and it's kind of goes
back to gender or the sexuality fluid
[__] is like
there is a little bit people are into
everything yeah and there's a little bit
of like from the moment you're born
you're like you get either implicit or
explicit messages of what it's okay to
be into right so from the time we're
little kids it's like especially when we
were growing up and maybe even further
back it's like what it's okay to be into
for us is like hot like probably blonde
probably you know what i mean like
there's a specific
yeah a type of beauty and you get those
messages and it like kind of [__] up
and that's not actually what everybody's
into you know what i mean like that's
probably most people are probably
there's a larger percentage of people
who are probably into that thing but
it's not exclusive no and it's the same
way where it's like
people would [__] oh i mean you people
would [__] whatever dude and want to
enthusiastically if they weren't like if
they weren't worried about like backlash
or like not being seen as somebody who's
cool like it's also like it's also like
a a like you know
like why do like it's funny why do like
if if you do you know closeted guys who
like all their girlfriends are tens and
you're like well that guy doesn't
actually [__] women yeah you know what i
mean
there'd be one six and a half that no
one else gets that just absolutely does
it for him you know what i mean it's
like it's like it's like there's so i
don't know it's like it's all like a
complicated thing where if people would
be allowed to be into whatever we'd see
a lot more weird people that were so
much weirder looking a lot of whatever
and it's like yeah it's yeah look at the
church history that's when you see them
exactly yeah yeah because that is hidden
you don't have to show anybody what
you're googling and [__] and that's and
then you've got all these rooms or or
porn sites and you're like i'm not the
first guy yeah somebody made this site
because they like this [__] and i like
it and now we're in this together but
it's because now more than ever it's
like you see people kind of just doing
what makes them feel good yeah yeah yeah
and that's good which is cool feel good
it's great and i have friends who just
completely are like you know what i
don't think i'll i ever want a regular
relationship i think i want to just
[__] be out on my own have different
hook up with people and just kind of
like focus do my own [__] and those same
people like yeah and maybe i'm bot like
maybe i'm a little bi you know what i
mean like just like everyone is just
doing their own thing and it is it is
pretty [__] cool and then and then i
also think there's obviously like a
backlash of like some people kevin
spacey
don't do anything yeah yeah yeah yeah it
depends what you want to do right you
know
we're pretty open here but there's a
couple
that's coming though i'm telling you
that's coming like
kids
you'll be like i like getting [__] by
adults and then we're like oh well he
likes it that's all that's coming yeah
but like he's a [__] kid yeah and he
also would eat ice cream every day you
know what i mean it's like there
probably are like think about us right
when you were 12
how many times were you like i would i
wish my
biology teacher would bring me into this
broom closet and suck my dick oh my god
but it would have [__] warped your
mind probably you know what i mean yeah
oh i think would have been cool yeah
yeah i'm with you i'm with
i'm with you but it's like at the end of
the day my biology teacher was an old
man but i still would have done it
there is a good teacher i think there's
just the line of like when they get you
know when people can [__]
consent to some [__] that is the law
what about gender
what do you mean now you're getting
blurry with the gender stuff with like
kids uh
you know getting a
surgical [__] i think as long as there's
nothing
i think as long as there's nothing
permanent it's like a kid should be able
to do whatever the [__] they want as
long as they have like their biology
mate isn't necessarily
you know irreversible i think for for
the most part a lot of people are hyping
that up to be like oh they're putting
them on surgeries and doing this [__]
where in the reality it's like just a
kid wants to dress how they want to
dress be called what they want to be
called and that kind of thing and i
think like who gives a [__] the same
thing with drag queens everyone talking
about how kids shouldn't be allowed to
[__] drag queens shouldn't be able to
like read the kids it's like i mean some
drag queens are explicit that's like
some of them are just like this cartoon
character yeah you know what i mean like
it's nuanced it's the way it's the way
like you don't think like uh you know
where can you can you kid not take a
picture with spider-man and times
square also a character like come on
okay exactly that's a great point where
it's like okay what if it's a guy in a
elsa wig and he's wearing a thing and
he's shaved and he looks like elsa yeah
it's disney it's like is that and you
couldn't even tell really oh you would
have a problem with that but it's like
is that an issue it's just like you know
i think it's working on me
i think it's much you know it's it's
publicized because it's the most extreme
version it's sure clicks but it's it's
not a it's a mostly a non-issue yeah
it's just a way for them to spread out
race of course of course like how many
people did the bathroom issue really
affect but that was every [__] fox
news thing oh i know
yeah
and like calling them like what if it's
a trans pedophile i'm like do you want
to look at the odds yeah what about how
many of those actually are just regular
pedophiles how about we do something
about regular pedals
give them their own bathroom
that's how we bust them he went into the
pedophile
and it's also like i don't want to be a
hack because everybody on twitter like
basically ratio that dump what's that
dumb [__] lauren beaubert
where she was like she was like well you
got to keep him send kids to church not
drag shows it's like
where do kids really get [__] lauren
yeah do they get where morgan's been so
those aren't the only two options yeah
there's other [__] kids chuck e cheese
yeah can we go in the middle dz man and
her
dz shout out what a [__] place pizza
pizza wasn't as good as chuck e cheese
it was all bad pizza but it's awesome
all pizza is good dc had way more of the
like it was more of an adventure though
yeah you felt like a big kid when you
were a dc that was the first place i got
diddled
the guy called his dick
he did ski ball on mark's butthole he
[__] threw it in
he just just three kids lined up with
their asses out pedophile skee-ball
he got 100 the hottest one was 100
some fat kids i'm like ugly kid with
pimples is 10.
[Laughter]
that was only a quarter
those look like a fun place to take a
kid dude
absolutely but you don't want to get a
germaphobe in that ball pit no i mean
that's fecal matter all day long baby
yeah every time i swim in a hotel pool
i'm like i'm just bathing in urine
you're 100 but whatever whatever it's
good for the skin
i love a nice kevin spacey told us
our kelly
i was a bed wetter yeah
you know a lot of kids 22 years older
right about 14. that's crazy yeah 14 is
wild that's all for that was there ever
anything that kicked it was there ever
like an end do you ever feel like i'm
clean
uh i kicked it eventually at around 13
14 but then when i would drink it came
back so i peed on a lot of one-night
stands
you talk about embarrassing my god i
mean you're already disappointing them
sexually because you're so drunk
and then you wake up you're both covered
in piss and it's their bed you know
we're all young and poor in college it
was brutal man you disappointed him and
then like your piss is like the nick
fury part of the marvel movie where it
shows up at the end
more
yeah and it's that been drinking all
night pissed it's like syrupy
you weren't getting [__] eight
glasses of water then i know
that [__] is yellow remember drinking
when you're young and you were just dude
the amount of beer we were just drinking
bouncing
i can't imagine like i'll drink beer now
but it's like back then when you're just
like i'll just have like
14 [__] natty likes it was just i
know
honestly
at my brother's wedding i had like
[__]
18 beers dude i was [__] up i was
because i don't like i said i don't
drink a lot so it's like i'm a [__]
huge these days too so i'm just like
keep them and they were [__] most of
them were ipa oh i was that's a bad
drone i was getting white
alcohol content i was getting [__] i
had a great time but yeah but then i got
covered immediately after that i think
probably i lowered my yeah my immune
system a little bit
i i would get i feel like i just get
sick when i get it does not all the time
but every once in a while you get a
hangover and you're like oh this is
gonna be like eight days yeah hangover
that goes into a cold absolutely one of
the worst because it's like it's like
all the [__] yeah because you're not
everything else you're doing is horrible
for you too exactly and you're getting
[__] up and no sleep and if you took
the booze out of it you'd still get sick
right the booze just takes it to the
[__] next level and also the beer
you're pissing all night the lack of
sleep is the problem now you're waking
up to piss i'll tell you what's been
great for hangovers lately is i'll do a
lot of natural wine no hangover almost
no hangover interesting but the problem
is you're just still bloated all the
time so like oh this is what like an
o'doul's drinker you still kind of feel
like crappy yeah yeah but you're just
not hungry yeah there's one very simple
solution which is like
you know stop change the name of the
show
you know what i mean like we're in too
deep stuff yeah it's too late now we're
in too deep yeah i love it any any
wrecks from you guys oh i got to say
have you seen i picked this for you okay
but it's also great
we own this city i haven't yet i
it's baltimore it's i i have the book i
started reading oh really yeah it's
david simon david did he write the book
no no he didn't write the book but it's
the wire guys he made it and he is so
good in it the accent is hilarious i've
heard that i've heard the clips he nails
it it's great i did jim and sam with him
the day really the day
it was like a news story because he was
the day where he was like yeah kevin
spacey is a piece of [__] that's awesome
because they were in baby driver
together and he said uh
you [__] that guy and it became i was
getting picked up by news outlets like
john bernthal says kevin spacey sucks
and i was like wow we didn't we all know
he's a rapist right but this is before
that was before yeah i think he was just
saying he's a dick damn that's sick good
for him dude because he wasn't even
really popping yet like burn though i
mean now he feels like he's [__]
untouched he was in stuff then though i
feel like that post punisher post
yeah okay yeah i think he's one of those
dudes
he's [__] he's incredible he's good
he nails this role and it's fun it's
shot well it's cool
wolf of wall street yeah he was so good
in that oh yeah
yeah oh [__] i gotta go watch shot
caller
fury wow
yeah um
on my wreck
yeah that's a good one i'm definitely
gonna see it um
my wreck is uh
you know this happening by accident but
i'm gonna wreck
uh i don't know if it's called edging or
what it is but
i was i was getting uh
i was getting sucked off recently
and there was a moment of
miscommunication and you know where
you're like there's like there's like a
millisecond right when you're about to
bust where it's like if you stop it's
just like the mo you're just like your
body's like well what the [__] you're
not gonna bust they did kind of like
it's like a cartoon where it's like you
put your hand on the gun and it's like
you know just kind of explodes and it
goes back in the barrel
you know and uh this so i was getting
sucked off and i was just like i was i
don't know what i sound like keep going
i just said something i must have been
mumbling because i'm like [__] about
to bust is the best the only good moment
of that day and uh
and she just stops she just goes what
complete takes her in complete hand and
mouth completely off my piece i'm like
i'm like i'm gonna pause i'm like it's
gonna come off i'm just like what the
[__] she stopped right then in there and
then
i was like all right well it'll come
back i guess i'll bust a second she goes
back and sucking me off my dick feels
weird it's like tingling and it's like
and i'm like what the [__] is going on
it feels like [__] i'm mad i'm like i
gotta get this out of me you know what i
mean like right my dick feels like i'm
both about to come and not about to come
at the same time it feels so strange and
then i finally did bust the nut like 10
minutes later and i was just like oh
like my eyes rolled in the back of my
head it was [__] insane and now i get
why sting does all that weird tantric
literally came like women come when i
was like oh
you know
it lasted long i was like what the [__]
is going i was confused never felt
anything like that before this song
bring on the night is about huh yeah he
couldn't stand another second in
daylight he was dying yeah in the end
let me see if i got it yeah you you get
blown you're right about the bus right
about the bus at the moment you're about
to bus you stop okay you let it go and
you're like oh you know and then you let
it cool off and then go right back to
getting
you put out the orgasm basically oh wow
that's almost like you bust two at once
damn it was [__] weird i was like
what the [__] i literally went so she
knew what she was doing here no not at
all [__] completely happy accident
damn
this is like how potato chips were
invented it was an accident
actually truly this is just random fat
knowledge i have that is how um the
like crescent rolls in a thing were
invented where somebody
only had time to bake them halfway and
had to stop and then came back and matt
thought they were going to be like
rotten or whatever and they were like
whoa these seem kind of fine and then
like re re-bake them and like realize
like oh we could like we could halfway
do them whatever and then just you just
have to finish them for five minutes and
they're fine so actually yeah it wasn't
wow
they edged the questions yeah
yeah that's interesting a lot of [__]
was that tea was an accident leaves tea
leaves fell into a boiling pot of water
tea look at that yeah fun fact yeah that
was happened like 7 000 years ago yeah
some chinese guy who was just hanging
out exactly trying to make soup
he was edging and he's like
oh [__] some leaves are falling [__] it
uh
all right good to know
i would say give it a whirl but it is it
was tough you know yeah yeah it's gonna
be tough to re oh here we go right
was this the slinky the slinky accident
posted no all accidents that was a
post-it note in accident i was an
accident
were you plato was an accident
damn
damn happy accident chocolate chip
cookies what the [__] no i mean that's
just [__] complete that's a that's a
slam dunk i just didn't melt him yeah
that's he must have felt awesome
popsicle 11 year old boy you see old
dudes and velcro sneakers it just looks
fun yeah they just gave up completely so
i had such wide feet as a child and big
feet i was like like now my you know i
wear like a weird my feet are bizarre
they're 11 and a half
6e the widest
the widest you can get really i can only
buy new balances in like a couple shoes
where i'm comfortable but when i was a
little kid i had like i'm like i'm you
know i was eight years old with like
size 8 double wide feet and it was like
i was wearing old men's velcro shoes
because i was like i also couldn't tie
my shoes until late for whatever reason
yeah and so i just would wear velcro and
at first they make velcro for little
kids you know obviously but then my feet
were so big and i was that i was wearing
like orthopedic old man's velcro yeah i
was just like in third grade with just
like the females i play basketball and
stuff what do you do
i haven't played basketball since i
figured out what my actual foot and
there's like there's a couple shoes that
fit me and i just stuck with them i wore
the iverson's in
three boxes the reeboks i wear the
iverson's in middle school i wore
um
i wear the dwayne wade comverses you
remember those those are pretty good
those are pretty good for the foot um
what else couple jordans just like it's
really just like it's really just like
shoot a shoe you have to try it on and
see see what fits for you but so are you
girthy
no come on
really just a regular run-of-the-mill
[__]
it's really a bru like if women know how
big my feet are and then see my dick
it's a real it's a real letdown
the feet thing is a myth my dad has tiny
like asian lady feet and he's got a huge
hog he's got a huge [__] and it tastes
great too
it tastes good
dude yeah we should [__] we should
have some oozo you guys got to come to
queens dude we're gonna have some uzo go
get some [__] greek food just we
gotta get grabbed octopus
come through dude that's the most
underrated food
so good i know that grilled octopus girl
calamari
yeah i'm sad i know i really don't think
i'm going to go back this year just
because like
traveling seems like the least like what
i want to do is not have to travel
that's what's not stressful to me right
now for people to understand
like we have a wedding and this and i'm
like [__] hey that's what happened
this tour at the end of i was booked
everything but two weeks and the like
leading up to the special release and
the only two weeks were my brother's
bachelor party and his wedding so they
weren't real weekends off though
that's harder on your body yeah yeah
yeah absolutely travel you get why these
guys go first class they go private jet
it's just it's the travel that kills you
yeah the gigs aren't bad at all the gigs
are fine these are nothing yeah it's
like yeah gigs are fun the green room is
nice yeah the hotel is nice but that
travel because it's this hotel though
i'm starting to like
i just want to be in my [__] shitty
little bed do you do airbnb sometimes i
do airbnb sometimes yeah especially if
i'm traveling with the crew because it's
just like you get a nicer house you
don't have to [__] you know
four hotel rooms that's just that's a
lot of money that's a p i'm getting sick
of checking in why does that take
11 minutes or 18 minutes you know okay
what's your last name do you have an id
i hate that process you just turned into
dice you're like
come on come on
give me the key
well the the gym's over here we have
breakfast at this time i'll figure it
out i'll figure it out yeah you know
what the words when they give you the
map of the city they're like let me show
you where to go
i wonder if i could find that on my
phone right here holy [__] they're
circling [__] get out of here
no i i definitely uh
you check especially the places that
won't check you for whatever reason you
land at one and they're like oh it's not
available until three and you're like
brutal i'm checking in on a thursday
yeah the hotel was at capacity on
wednesday that's what you want me to
believe there was no room available for
me right now you [__] [__] and i
know it's a hack joke but it's so true
like check in as it's 7 p.m check out us
at 4 00 am you know they just keep
moving back and back yeah yeah yeah with
the police of that joke
remember that joke he had about he
checks into the hotel and there's a
there's a [__] in his toilet and he
calls the front desk and goes you know
most hotels leave a mint on your pillow
use some classic road jokes oh yeah
yeah man it's uh it's the best though i
do i still love the road it's weird i do
too i do too if it what i the way i
describe it is if it wasn't destroying
my body it would be heaven well like
every choice no but but even the
drinking what let's let's see let's look
at your livers in a couple years
[__] coaching so that's what
they said the liver is very resilient
my my advice shows up right away you
[__] are going to have
cirrhosis in 10 years
marcon is liver
[Laughter]
but that's it's like it's just like
like doing what you love the most
traveling and seeing cool cities getting
[__] up eating like good food getting
the [__] girl just like that is if
that's what i want heaven to be yes or
being on the a sold-out tour with your
best friends
and you feel
no hangovers no nothing
first class [__] sweets that's heaven
that's literally
you're on the flight you're first class
you're sitting next to a milf yeah yeah
you're edging absolutely
the flight attendant walks over what are
you doing she starts sucking you too
yeah
this is the good this is the first ice
meal the first class meal is popeyes
[Laughter]
that's literally what heaven would be
for me and then you know you get to see
your family during the holidays
but yeah but it's like it's
unfortunately there are body limitations
you know what i mean like whatever but
oh no we're feeling it i i don't feel
good
my body is definitely not doing well the
lack of sleep is is what kills me that's
what [__] me every article is like
dementia is from lack of sleep i'm like
cool yeah yeah i remember my grandma at
the end she was telling the same stories
every day i know she was singing
zippity-doo-dah she was not making a lot
of sense you're gonna be the old folks
how i'm doing i got this
i just wrote this [__] it's pretty new
stop asking me where i'm from sir yeah
oh my god i'm gonna be trying doing
crowd work with the nurses
[Laughter]
where do you work here sir now let me
change your diaper
where are you from sir i'm from jersey
i'll talk slower
sir
you're senile
that does scare me because we we know
comics will be telling the same stories
oh already yeah picture them in like 40
years yeah i know i know that's tough we
should all quit comedy
yeah i think that's whenever people get
back and they quit and then they come
they're like i'm back and i'm like
it's like shawshank yeah you made it
yeah yeah
yeah no it's the mafia where it's like
there's no way out and the rare guys
that do it's like never come back like
you figured out like we're we have no
other
choice tries to get out of the sopranos
because he inherits that money yeah it
just ends with him hanging himself
that's comedy that's your only way out
yeah that's it
i mean now as i really i saw a guy
recently you ever have this happen where
he was like oh
i'll send you i'll send you my set not
like would you watch my set like
i'll send it to you i'm like it's like a
favor
yeah of course i hate when people ask
for favors but they do it it's like i'm
gonna do this yeah yeah yeah all right
you ever you ever have the guy who you
started doing comedy with and he just
fizzled out and you're like oh whatever
happened like and then you see him
he's always way happier yeah he's always
working somewhere and he's like how are
you man i'm married now i got two kids i
i i'm a pilot or whatever you're like oh
good for you yeah until you hear about
that guy in the news you're like yeah he
crashed the plane
you think he was happy but he was not he
was doing his act in the announcements
yeah i think about this did the german
wings guy remember that [__] oh german
wings pilot was just awesome wait you
told me the guy who was being who is who
suicide oh i killed a whole plane of
people
that guy stole a plane did loop-de-loops
with no training was just sick at flying
the plane and then crashed it was a
pretty cool way to kill yourself pretty
cool pretty cool way to kill him he's
funny on the radio it was hilarious yeah
i'm gonna think of another one there was
one no no i know the one you're talking
about mine didn't have people in it who
deliberately crashed the german wings
airliner killing himself in 149 oh
that's [__] up yeah that sucks that's
not cool but our guy is cool yeah that's
right most ways to commit suicide
totally here's a wreck for you you ever
see the movie wild tales it's an
argentinian movie it's like a bunch of
vignettes it's awesome one of them i'm
gonna give away one of them because
there's six but one of them is a bunch
of people on a flight
and they're all they start chatting with
each other and they're kind of like oh i
know this person too like how do you
know i think you've told me this they
all it turns out they all know the pilot
and he crashes the plane yeah
they're all people who have like wronged
him in a way that's great it's a bunch
of weird [__] up
stuff
stories it's a great movie
um wild tape yeah i want to get in
that's great i'm gonna a big part of my
time off is just like i'd lo i'm just
gonna just [__] watch a bunch of
movies yeah i just want to get in there
do the movie today i'm get i love i love
a triple feature i got i got a
i have a projector in my house it's
[__] like a hundred inch screen it's
[__] sick yeah yeah and i upgraded it
so it's like i used to be like you know
i used to have like a shitty one where
it's like you just couldn't watch it if
it wasn't pitch black but now i got one
you have a sunny day can you watch games
in there too oh yeah that's pretty bad i
watch all the games on there yeah ufc
guy i'm not a big user
i used to be i used to be when i was
younger but uh i don't know it's just
like honestly once you start doing
comedy you only have so many true and
i'm a hoops guy you know what i mean
it's like staff and i text hoops every
day yeah i know but my brothers are ufc
guys so whenever i'm home i like to like
i like to we might your brothers is into
it huh both of them both of them yeah
george and nick both my brothers are
into uh they're into uh uh ufc stuff and
so you know like we were teens the the
the ritual because when the ufc was like
really starting to you know it was like
the chuck liddell yeah yeah you know
that era who was the other guy who was
the guy he had the rivalry with
tito ortiz the other guy i'm talking
about he's an older guy randy couture oh
yeah
he knocked him out yeah yeah yeah kids
were [__] awesome and then obviously
um you know
uh silva was i mean unbelievably
unbelievable um anyway uh we would watch
we would go to the buffalo wild wings in
white marsh maryland and just get there
an hour before the pay-per-view just
hold down a table right across really
and just like
spend our spend my like you know
i remember what the [__] my job was your
paycheck yeah my i worked at blockbuster
for a summer
really yeah i loved that gig one they
told me that
one of the managers was like hey we only
pretend to send people to collections if
they take dvds we can't really do
anything about it and when they told me
that i've checked out 10. she kept them
and quit
do you remember the movies one of them
was like platoon i remember platoon was
one of them yeah that's a good one um
there was a bunch of scorsese because
that was the summer i was like i want to
like learn a little bit about movies you
know so i i uh uh cape fear the scorsese
fear uh
you know weirdly like how to lose a guy
in ten days or just one whatever rom-com
was around a girl over yeah yeah yeah
yeah you need one uh i don't remember
the rest of them though platoon i
definitely i watched it for whatever
reason i watched platoon a lot that
summer but it was kind of cool it was
still in dvd times it was still yeah
yeah charlie
charlie sheen's a dream guest on
we've talked about it many times guys
got stories
we're gonna need more than alcohol
he's gonna go all in he'd have some
[__] in here yeah yeah he's got a new
thing coming out really yeah with the
with the entourage guy they're working
on something wow
could be good two and a half [__]
i would love to have graham the next
thing he does yeah that's what i have
charlie sheen's good dude he's a good
actor he's good that's exactly what we
talked about before you don't have to be
a good a person to be good at something
no
you know look at brawn the [__] nazi
guy's a hell of a hell of a scientist
all right charlie sheen oh here we go oh
dramedy i don't like that
yeah dramedy is one of the honestly a
really tough genre to pull off it can be
great though it can be but it's tough if
you just hit the landing i need high i
was hoping for a much more harder comedy
thing because that's what i think you
should do
there's something really funny is he in
the photo
unless they consider entourage of
dramedy
i don't think so yeah it's a pure comedy
all right well good for you chuck
martin sheen whoa
[Music]
all right john c mcginley oh jamie lee
single we got some interesting names
mark cuban didn't he have a hiv uh
machine
yeah i believe so all right still
cooking
you can yeah that's easy to get if
you're rich you're fine is that what it
is i feel like at this point hiv is not
that i mean you don't want to get it
obviously but it's like you can
it's it's honestly a discussion whether
you want herpes or hiv yeah
i think it's like i think it's like a
it's like not quite a coin flip but hiv
has become more of uh you know yeah one
of our i guess the same thing with
herpes as long as you take the pills and
[__] true you're good yeah one of our
good friends is has herpes and is
married and his wife is fine wow
we're all going to pretend like we don't
know who we're talking
so is everyone listening right
we will
i think it's funnier not to say it
that person is shane gillis
no no no he's not married but should we
do bits oh he did one i did one sorry i
didn't want to do one let's do it you go
i'm looking i got there's an idea i have
about like wow this is a dizzy angle i
have
you ever you ever do this in a
relationship you ever pop an adderall
and just really listen
that's my angle
well you just like really oh it's like
it's like viagra but for your for your
relationship
so i think the angle is like funny how
that's like the new thing is like
listening is the new thing where you're
like uh
you know back in the day you know it's
viagra but it's anyone get a rock hard
[__] and you actually feel like special
after 45 minutes of like um yeah yeah
i like that i mean the premise got
trying to do this whole thing about uh
you know prostitution because i have a
lot of uh prostitutes in my neighborhood
at night they come out and i know you're
supposed to say sex worker but i feel
like i've given them enough money i
should be able to call them whatever i
want
and that hits but my whole point of the
joke that's like a little lead-in the
point of it is
sex is weird because we all like having
sex couples have sex but it's the only
thing that gets sadder when you go pro
nothing else is like that
maybe bowling yeah
i got that bowling gets you know if you
got a friend he's a great bowler that's
cool you got a friend he's a pro bowler
like what's up with this guy yeah you
know something's off
i like that set and then you can have a
bunch of examples obviously like what's
good is just like you know pro athlete
right you know pro you know right
comedian whatever it is
yeah professionally but yeah you're
right sex worker is there anything else
yeah either way but you spent all your
time in a mall or something like that i
don't know something like getting good
at bowling is the only thing is getting
good at bowling like you have to work so
much yeah it's so much work right that's
like being up being a little worker they
don't look like they do a lot
of pro bowler
yeah they look rough yeah maybe that's
the i like that yeah it's like man i
know you have a lot of money but you
look like [__] yeah yeah yeah
like a prostitute
and then something maybe we're like
getting holes are getting fingered in an
alley
is that two is that too rich
i see what you're saying yeah but gutter
i don't know we got something around
ally
yeah three fish getting fingered in an
alleys but there that's the bowl that's
the ball fingering in an alley
you know you know but yeah that's not
his but as soon as you're saying it it
doesn't wrap up nice
there's something there it's up there it
just puts a bow on it
um all right i'll play with that yeah
okay oh you know what i thought i had a
uh
okay here's here's something that i i
can't i need a little something more to
it i'm going through the old stuff
actually this is good because i i got to
a point after i was running this hour
where i was like
for a while i was like oh thank you
buddy for a while i was like i got to do
something new every time and i was
really but then i just got burnt out i
was like let me just [__] get through
this [__] tour yeah it was good that
i'm like going through this [__] um
was like i um
like i stopped i was
because i'm trying to you know get a
handle on my eating so i i was i figured
i'd be sober for a while so that way
it's like you know you eat better if
you're not drunk you're not high but now
i'm just completely sober
getting up and standing in line for a
low grade cheesesteak at 2am right which
is like so much more morally
devastating
just be complete stone completely aware
of it and just in a bodega like
yeah i'll take the cheesesteak please
you know what i mean just like so i
don't know there's just like there's
something there but i'm just like you
just have a different drug doing the
exact same thing yeah yeah it's
well what's worse knowing you're about
to eat a shitty cheesesteak or being
drunk and getting a shitty cheesesteak
in a in a [__] up state yeah at least
the alcohol you were blocking this out
like exactly with the wheat like that's
a problem with drugs that heighten your
awareness yeah yeah
when you're making bad decisions yeah
already right you know maybe that's like
the end where it's like that's why on
adderall you don't eat because you're
aware you're so focused on how [__]
horrible that is yeah when you're drunk
you're like ah but now i'm just like oh
i just really want this i'm just face to
face with the reality that this is what
i want right that's the angle where it's
i can't blame it on anything else yeah
this is who i'm a guy who gets this
[__] cheese you should do that for
other like other things like the women
you're [__] like everything is just
you're like no this is just me yeah yeah
it's just what i do i only [__] a guy
when i was drinking
when you're sober you're like i really
want to [__] a guy
you blame it on the booze but it's just
what you want yeah there's some
i just haven't been able to cry i just
think there is something very funny to
that idea of being like god damn it this
was
that didn't help you know what everybody
i have to actually look at what the
problem is instead of hoping a different
whatever maybe the angle of the line is
like it sucks when you find out alcohol
is not the problem yeah yeah like i'm
the yeah you're the problem it's not
it's not your drug addictions it's you
yeah yeah it's going way deeper yeah
yeah yeah
that's that's a nice angle
you blame the booze but the booze is
actually just an out because you can go
oh it's because i was drunk yeah but
it's just yeah just who you are you go
back to drinking you're like well at
least now i have a scapegoat you know i
mean exactly that's a scapegoat
okay this is good i have a bunch of
[__] that i forgot to [__] let's
found some bits man um
i wonder if orgies have the same rules
as like uh
like road trips where it's like do
little guy do do guys with little dicks
get to call shotgun they get to go first
guy he gets to go first gets shotgun
always something right does a guy with a
little ass penis get to get the [__]
[__] first you know
a little these are all and then uh
close to that is anal is little dick
reparations is what i have written down
here
i forgot about these and then uh this
one i think there might be something
here but you know it's barely hanging
out with your friends in your 30s is
just reverting back to childhood where
it's like now their girlfriend is their
mom where it's like
dude don't get popcorn dude let's not
get popcorn all over the couch i don't
want to get yelled at this is great you
know what i mean like this is great and
you want to [__] them both yeah
like your mom's pretty hot yeah when
you're in the 30s you're like your
girlfriend's pretty hot well in your 30s
you have to pretend you don't want to
[__] here
[Laughter]
dude i want to [__] your mom and they're
like dude come on they'll play with the
hot mom dude come on yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're right now you have
to be able to be like oh yeah no she's
pretty woman i'm so happy for you pal
yeah and i've never thought about
getting head from her
all right we might have got something i
think we got some boys that's something
there for sure yeah the mom the
girlfriend being the mom is is a rich
premise yeah i bet that's great her
she's scolding you yeah because the only
times you ever hang out is
what you're doing the stuff you would do
like when it's just you yeah and when
his girlfriend's away is the same way as
when their mom left you completely for a
sleepover video games drinking snacks
it's literally the exact same thing i
love it
as you did when you're all right we got
something there yeah the only difference
is your friend goes and [__]
you know just going to bed with you yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's interesting that's
a great great observation all right all
right i had one that did all right i
think there's something here about uh
gun people who like it's their whole
personality and it just bugs me when
they act like it's only for emergencies
and then you see their profile picture
on twitter and they're in front of a
sunset like this
and i'm like yeah that's not where you
like my profile pick is not me with an
epipen
i hope i never have to use this you know
what i mean
like pen is great yeah epipen or
something like maybe plan b could be
funny or like if i [__] if i shoot a
load yeah so help me god i'll [__]
you have one of those bandoliers filled
with plan b's
it's just one of the things where i'm
like this is the first thing i need to
know about you right right that you have
guns yeah it's only for emergency yeah
no that's really good the epipen
analysis i like to open in tampa by
going and believe me i know where i am
yes i'm not saying like i i get it yeah
but
i'm gonna [__] on you yeah what else is
only for emergencies
epipen is good happy fire extinguisher i
did i did i tried fire extinguisher i
said shoot i said spray a whole school
yard that's what i said
so help me god i'll spray a schoolyard
with this
that's good something there definitely
something there airbags yeah oh airbags
airbags
the only problem is you don't choose
when those come out you know yeah but
then
um let's see here let's see here there's
gun the gun stuff is always like it's
hard to find gun angles that haven't
been i got a gun
because this is i think it's an
ambitious bit so i need some help here
so i'm not a gun guy
i get people want to have guns but i
don't know if an 18 year old needs a
semi-automatic weapon
so
my compromise is we got to treat it like
a wedding you got to show up to the gun
shop with invited friends and family and
when the gun store owner goes does
anyone have any objections
to these two coming together
and forever now you know hold your piece
whatever and now it's a public thing so
one guy can go
i just want to say i grew up with this
guy and he tried to [__] my dog or
something something ridiculous yeah it's
like really you should have a gun you
lost at halo and you threw a chair out
your window
right like something like that you know
yes and they can speak up because it's
weird they can buy this in secrecy right
you know so it should have to be a
public thing with the wedding you know
there should be at least be a vote a
vote you at least have to get fifty
percent right
at the very least yeah yeah and then
every time that someone does a shooting
we should get to see the results it was
like look he eaked it out fifty one
forty nine sorry you know what i mean
yeah that's good you know i don't know
that's good and then i want to do a
thing like at the end where i say
uh you know a lot of people wait till
marriage to have sex you have to have
had sex to get the gun yeah it should be
reversed
and the girls got to come in like i
[__] in my [__]
that's really good that's really good
because it's the whole it kind of ties
into like the in-cell angle to
shootings yes
that could be like let me see that that
trigger finger
okay that one checks out
it's also so funny that like how [__]
we are with the gun debate where it's
like
your your tone at the beginning of the
premise was like
now
the the controversial thing you want
people to give you a second on is that
18 year olds shouldn't have
semi-automatics i know right like how
much gun people have won they can't get
it
we're not even talking about should they
have guns yeah we're talking about
should teenagers have semi-automatics
exactly that's [__] insane any
teenagers
but yeah yeah yeah right
yeah i love people who anyway whatever
we're gonna have to have the gun control
the baby yeah we don't have no yeah yeah
yeah that's not we this is escapist
drinking yeah yeah we already covered it
i know peters
it's freaking hot i'm sweating it's a
little hot
glasses i don't want to know i just want
to i want a yeah i want to kiss too
all right let me get the bodega cat baby
so what's the setup here you guys did it
with uh
with chris our friend christopher give
me a little bit too i want you so just a
little bit mm-hmm
smelling rich
oh yeah
salud
get on this
we're almost out we need another bottle
chris we're sending us a [__] bottle
dude
that's good isn't that good
i like that boys that's a little rye
yeah
yeah it's good stuff
i love it you got you guys got [__]
whiskey deals now we're trying we're
trying i'm comfortable
i had a lozo in there it helped
absolutely went down easy love whiskey
all right good bits boys good pods great
special i mean obviously you guys to
know know to watch stuff special please
watch the special subscribe to the
youtube channel i also i have a special
up there but i also do a short every day
and uh i do it's amazing you do it every
day i do a short every day and i do
twice a week i do um longer video like
longer crowd work clips
twice a week yeah something between you
know two and a half to five minutes
something like that and then could you
pull that up again i forgot what my
dates are
this is coming out i'm going to love the
google history after this is just ice
cream
and then yeah so i'm doing a little mini
i'm taking most of the year off but i'm
doing a little mini run i'm doing
phoenix uh pittsburgh denver richmond
and i'm probably going to add something
in december and i'll probably be doing
shows in the city just working on the
hour just kind of like you know getting
it getting it getting it going and then
are you doing comedy works downtown i am
that's nice have you been there i've
been there i did a sunday it's amazing
it's great one of the great club love it
honestly i like the one
i like the one in the burbs too it's
good too it's a really good one yeah the
theater theater style it feels like a
theater for papa there oh nice love pop
and the king he rules and uh
and um
it was just really i mean just great
clubs in general comedy works anyway you
slice it and so yeah oh i got a shirt
it's amazing i got another new shirt
[__] dude i want the stavi greek yogurt
one i'll bring it to you
can you go to my twitter actually dude
because i have a new shirt i have a
shirt with uh this guy bread press who
does incredible
really he does incredible yeah actually
i gotta [__] put it i gotta add it to
my
gotta add it to my website but if you
scroll down just a little bit
i have a new shirt oh they have me
[__] blocked
um
yeah celebrate that one go to view go to
view of celebrate the most hard dick
yes
so i have a sp i have a t-shirt to
commemorate the special oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's great it's really [__] good
this guy bread press does good stuff and
yeah so those are limited edition go go
get those little [__] but yeah the
youtube channel i'm really investing in
my youtube a lot it just feels like the
way to do that
so yeah please follow me there guys and
please watch the special and you know
twitter instagram all that stuff and
come out and see me thanks boys thanks
for having me yeah yeah i'm i'm doing a
big tour i'm pumped a lot of dates just
added uh yeah west palm beach buffalo
san jose i told you you have to take a
[__] week off l.a
fort wayne kansas tacoma fort wayne you
piece of [__]
instead of instead of instead of
sleeping in your bed you're going to
[__] fort wayne indiana i've been
there now you're out of your [__]
mind that's a rough room i can heckle
there for a month is that [__]
thanksgiving you're going to fort wayne
on thanksgiving
you just you know what you deserve
everything all the back pain you deserve
it [__] no they'll give you a
turkey sandwich in there it's just like
home
you're sick in the [__] head you're
spending thanksgiving in fort wayne
indiana yeah you're busy you brought
food in
he's like thanksgiving you ruined it
all right
i'm all over the road mark is about to
judge me but he's taking even less
weekends off you got that right i'm
doing the bert fully loaded tour that'll
be fun i got the uh the brandon oh sorry
hold on city winery in new york la jolla
irvine improv
uh come out to that that's a fun room
yeah the vogel in new jersey
uh count basie theater i think that's in
connecticut maybe
wise guys salt lake city keep going keep
going houston improv big room help me
out there lexington
uh what else lol san antonio we got a
comedy connection we got the wilbur we
got the neptune we got portland we got
vancouver we got toronto we got the joy
new orleans so we got all kinds of stuff
where you playing in vancouver
some danforth
danbury musical or something like that
it might be drunkpod.com get your merch
get your cool glasses all that [__]
gotham studios we love you peters uh
mccoy thanks for for filling in here
bodega cat coming very soon hell yeah we
love you guys thanks for
[Music]
a little too listening
burping and norman's talking [__] about
the [__] post and i get down in the
same way
up on the roof like a cop's coming and
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we might
be
true
[Music]